the girag an experienced Joe did anyone
sends you that grand theft auto DMT trip
a lot of people think that you had a big
influence in it
I'm sure there's a lot of people done
DMT besides me but it starts off with
this you know guy and you're just
driving around with your your father and
then he the kid tricks him into taking
it while he's driving so he starts
tripping out but you usually protected
essa ties me your [ __ ] [ __ ] Tech to
you from yourself sort your money from
your bank account
- crazy dead isn't that on the ground
tripping balls yeah and then watch what
happened this is the part where it
starts getting really Joe Rogan II my
okay this is a [ __ ] awesome video
holy [ __ ]
Bigfoot's calm
it's something
there's ago do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
oh gee this is no way you can get two
more tricks
oh yeah this meant people Oh
now he's getting abducted by aliens so
he the monkeys first and then the alien
ship shoots him up into its spaceship
this is honest I hate these people in me
are on the same wavelength if they
didn't hear me if they don't know of me
and know me when you were coding this
they need to search out we are on what a
you are you are the herpes that there's
no cure for we are on the same
wavelength we would get along great as
if they don't know me we would get along
great
if this wasn't inspired by me deafness
man's [ __ ] comic people everyone you
have permeated all of us did you see
that he did this that the alien gave him
the [ __ ] metal sign yeah wow this is
intense [ __ ] it is made this with no
underwear though that'd be a [ __ ] but
why are you hiding your dick and [ __ ]
you're you're flying to space you know
you shouldn't be holding on to your your
vanity in your fear and your
insecurities let the breeze blow through
that left flies let's hover on your
[ __ ]
with your flying around space what do
you care you're you're one with the
universe
so you
oh yeah and you can get high and every
time you get by you even hear inner
thoughts and it's really trippy so like
once it goes online October 1st always
comics are all just gonna hang out or
smoke weed together I heard this witness
can gets in the oculus rift I've heard
that this game is the the most
successful single piece of anything
anybody created ever 1 billion dollars
in three days not amazing it's amazing
but there's never been anything that's
sold as well as this god bless america
right when you think the economy's down
to cocaine or coca-cola in a day yes
it's only so much blow you can do I mean
after what I remember the one time I was
offered DMT by a buddy buddies buddy
we're up in Canada and he's like hey man
I got this [ __ ] this DMT and he's like
I'm uh he heard I'm like I'm familiar
I've heard of it I have I know some
people that have talked about it like
it's just a baby - why don't we go back
and we're all out drinking and hanging
out I'm like no you don't want to do DMT
we go back and just start shoving
[ __ ] hallucinogenic drugs up my body
with a guy that just ah yeah gosh man
but it does not sound like a good idea
I wake up lays like a [ __ ] Krispy
Kreme donut or happened you know that's
when somebody gets eaten yeah that could
happen - yeah especially when you're
drinking now usually nuts but you're not
even supposed to eat you too nonchalant
about slinging you know us [ __ ] doing
DMT I'm like that's
mm-hmm should be taken with a lot more
care want to give you some of that
what's the [ __ ] of Viking that's what
that is
no that's why you [ __ ] a Viking that is
not them up roof him up with some DMT ha
ha
you're a [ __ ] human being